we all love margot robbie i have like a
boy girl crush on margot robbie i love
her she would turn you straight
as close as i can get she could do it um
do you i loved her in the wolf of wall
street bombshell i tonya dude harley
quinn harley quinn hello
every girl and boys fantasy yes well now
she and actor sebastian stan uh want to
work together again you'll remember they
met on itanya he played jeff galuli who
was tanya's husband that's right
and now uprox reports their next dream
project is a 90s style classic rom-com
do we have anyone here who knows
anything about that
she does um
apparently apparently they love them
just like we all do and sebastian says
he's seen notting hill which is one of
the best ever
medicine he says he's seen it so many
freaking times because it's his ultimate
plane movie
do you watch rom-cons on planes what do
you watch i watch rom-coms all the time
oh you do oh yeah yeah what's the best
one that you're not in because i would
say the best ones ever are the ones that
you're in that's so nice of you there
are so many wonderful offerings out
there i'm not being nice i'm telling you
hello i'm telling the truth oh and this
is where my mom like sends me text she's
like stop rejecting people's compliments
you're so gracious to other people let
them let it soak in okay mom that one's
for you thank you rob
you're welcome thank you i appreciate
that very much you're welcome um i just
watched i just rewatched um knocked up
and
which is just uh judd apatow came on the
show and i'm literally going through his
whole catalog um right now funny enough
i love the movie the breakup and i was
watching it the other night and i was
like oh i can't handle this right now oh
really uh-uh like i just i remember when
i got a divorce i couldn't watch the
handmaid's tale and then five years
later i was like bring it on yeah you
know you just have to be like in the
right mood but i love that movie i i
just love you know
we all like rom-coms that's a there's a
reason the genre works and i would go
see margot robbie and
uh
sebastian stan any day his role that he
did as tommy lee did anyone watch pam
and tommy oh my gosh
he
he did something that's so hard to do in
acting which is to keep pushing you to
the edge and
show your flaws and almost be unlikable
but then pull you back in time and time
again and be like
those are just his flaws he's
you know i'm i'm on the ride with him
i'm there and that's not an easy art to
do and then she is everything so yes yes
yes yes and anything especially at
rom-com all right uh next up we've got a
cleaning debate for the ages oh
god you thought rom-com's got me excited
i know and you have you have
stand for stains coming up with i am too
baby do i ever it's a big day for you
and i just started talking differently i
was like listen to it's baby doll i got
a thing for stains
um okay so this tur this story is uh
when cleaning the house when do you
vacuum so southern living reports that
the proper time to vacuum is actually
before and after your big top to bottom
house clean many people wait to vacuum
until the end and experts say that you
should really vacuum first and um you
know uh
and and last the first vacuum kicks all
the dust up and then you clean it and
you get that last vacuum uh whoa this is
wow double down yeah i don't like this
one bit i'll tell you what it already do
what vacuuming does it sucks literally
it sucks
i don't you're telling me to do it twice
now i don't think so hoover anyone here
think that vacuuming twice is a good
idea
what's your name by the way my name's
debbie debbie debbie and you love
vacuuming i love vacuuming i love
cleaning i love i'm ocd well what is it
i'm a lucky guy i'm not your husband i'm
a lucky guy
[Music]
you